bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono vari geni oggi
senza cuffie allora io non mi ricordo se
ve l'avevo mai fatta vedere questa cosa
abbiamo sull'attivo al canale qualcosa
come 1800 video sto dal controllo
no 2000 2.171 sono poco aggiornata
adesso mentre sto registrando ce ne sono
2.171 quindi smancerie quindi volevo
farvi vedere una roba che probabilmente
vi avevo già fatto vedere in live però
non avevo mai dedicato vida questa cosa
ho sempre voluto farlo ma ho sempre
allontanato l'idea nel tempo no devi far
vedere questa cosa perché ci sono molti
di voi che non l'hanno vista però quando
io ho iniziato a farlo youtuber nei
primi anni insomma mi contattò la la red
bull quella famosissima marca di
materassi no per gli scherzi mi ha
contattato la red bull e mi ha messo le
ali sul serio perché tempo fa feci la
red bull soft boxe race che cos'è la red
bull su box rails praticamente una gara
dove ti fanno guidare una macchina con
degli ostacoli all'interno della gara
con dei salti tipo mario kart non trovò
e deve arrivare fino alla fine e io fui
invitato non per fare il giudice ma per
guidare voi direte una sicura ma come
hai fatto a guidare una macchina che non
puoi guidare le macchine che
preannunciava lo so però la cosa bella
di questa gara che c'è presente c'era
una collina a torino sta collinetta
questa collina dove vi scendere e
schivare gli ostacoli problema
la macchina la bibita a forma di
macchina da un sacco ce ne sia davano
una macchina vera l'altro polacca la
discesa a un casino questo questa questa
impresa che ho fatto risale al 2014
appunto non avevo ancora i capelli la
marmotta ben ricordi e sono passati
ormai più di cinque anni da quando è
successo non l'ho mai pubblicata sul
canale e volevo pubblicarlo
magari se riusciamo anche commentando la
visto che non ho proprio il video
dedicato a questa cosa allora ragazzi
partiva dal presupposto che è da una
vita che non lo vedo
ecco saranno due anni che lo vedo sto
video credo bellissimo dato i miei
capelli mi stavano all'interno dio solo
sa come veramente fantastico con il
ciuffo zarina che mi esce meraviglioso
che da sola
no non ce l'avevo già in testa quindi
cosa mi ha lasciato amico mio non è che
non ho mai lasciato e che non avendo la
patente questa la prima macchina che
quindi le 19
avevo 19 anni dio mio guardami in faccia
come sono infantile bello che il sorriso
smile dell'iss
quindi se arrivi sulla parabolica con
troppa velocità
se non ci esci dalla parabola è bella
gomito e io l'ho vista prima ed è bello
che muore visti da vicino dagli alti
anche i saldi sono belli alti non me la
son sentito perché ho visto tanti video
in passato dove le macchine si sono
piantati proprio col vino meno male che
in quel momento mi stavo cagando sotto e
quindi non ho ascoltato quello che ha
detto perché io sia la parabolica che
dopo vedrete sia i salti li ho fatti se
io avessi ascoltato questa cosa non gli
avrei mai fatti il meno male che non
l'ho sentita e li ho fatti poi vedrete
un attimino solo ci siamo siamo ragazzi
in fondo se cerri e il freno se no ci ha
messo messo un freno a mano qualche cosa
serve il freno allora ho giocato a mario
kart e quindi più o meno non lo so è
uguale guarda la stessa cosa tu senti la
colonna sonora di quello e lasciati
guidare
ci siamo ti fanno segno il freno a mano
e quello lì va bene sono uguali o uno o
l'altro scegliete non è che il freno a
mano fi testa coda
sei pronto tipico pianoforte come ti
pare tanto da morire lo stesso succede
pronti esatto bravo il ragazzo
temerario bellissimo da dietro è un
altro tutta la gente che stava i lati
non mi conosceva ancora non essendo
ancora la faccia come molto più
impegnare c'è poco grande tutti mi
guardavano perché grande favi tutti mi
guardavano perché avessero fatto i nomi
di rotta in avevano deciso allora spiego
per quelli che dovranno farlo poi la
cicas bisogna andare vicino le prime
realtà ragazzi stamattina sta andando
sul serio
mi ero fatto uno che guarda che ha fatto
tutto fa l'ingegnere non ci credo ma
neanche io non faccio essere io non lo
so lo vedo lo vedo sta pero livelli
ragazzi io ho visto il muro nardò io ve
lo do per fare dopo dopo quel salto
libera che frenata dalla tattica dopo
quel salto di ragazzi ho sentito un male
un male al deretano per una settimana
giuro quello che volete perché il salto
che ho fatto
siccome la macchina non aveva proprio
tutti i confort dentro era un pezzo di
ferro con le ruote
ho dato la popolata su parlano parti di
sotto della macchina mi sono fatto male
che non una settimana ma è durato
orribile però ragazzi cresta lauria soft
boxe reiss era da un bel po che volevo
mettere questo video però non l'ho mai
dedicato no in realtà perché i tempi
avevo un sacco di di vito da far uscire
poi mi son dimenticato proprio che e poi
negli anni ho sempre voluto fare questa
questa sorta di action lavoro a tanti
forse ma probabilmente come video
dedicato ancora non c'era
spero che vi sia piaciuta a meno
cedendola scherza mi è piaciuto un sacco
anzi forse ad oggi dal ricordo come una
delle emozioni più grandi per guidare
anche perché l'unica è quindi spero che
vi sia piaciuto al collasso di gm sono
pronto mi piace iscrivetevi al canale
scusatemi se vide un po corto però
purtroppo già sono sopravvissuto per un
minuto e mezzo di corsa più lungo
probabilmente non sarei qui a
raccontarvelo quindi meglio che sia così
vano se non siete questi iscrivetevi e
noi come sempre ci vediamo hanno poi
subito dai ragazzi
[Musica]